-So, you play a judge
in this film.
-Play a judge, yeah.
-Did you speak to judges?
Did you spend time in the court?
-Yeah, I really --
It was absolutely fascinating.
Because I don't know
you have it here,
but it's the family court.
-Mm-hmm.
-And, of course,
the family court,
because it's about the most
important thing in the world,
is considered rather less
than the criminal court,
so it's a slightly poor cousin.
But, of course,
when you sit in the courtrooms,
you realize that
these people are presiding
over life and death
and watching terrible pain
and suffering.
And she's presiding over a case
about a Jehovah's Witness boy
who's refused
a blood transfusion.
But at the same time,
Stan Tucci, her husband,
has just thrown a hand grenade
into the marriage
and said,
"I'm going to have an affair."
So, it's all
about her balancing herself,
and it -- it's Ian McEwan,
so it's very, very interesting
and sort of complicated
and human, you know?
There's no black and white.
There's no goodies and baddies.
It's -- It's all the gray areas
of our lives
where we get totally confused
and don't know what to do.
-It's a fantastic part.
-Mm-hmm.
-I also noticed, of course, you
have to play piano in the film.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Is that --
And you have to play
some pretty serious piano,
not just joking-around piano.
Do you have skills as a pianist?
-Yeah. I --
I mean, I can play the piano,
but I had to --
I had to learn this
so that I could play it live.
So we -- we didn't pre-record
or anything like that.
So, my family threatened
to throw me out
because I rehearsed so much
over six months.
So, in the end, I used --
in the end, I went to rehearse
in a piano shop
on the Fulham Road.
And it was a big glass thing,
and I would be playing
the piano,
and people would be outside
looking in at the piano,
wondering about
whether perhaps to purchase it.
And perhaps, also wondering
whether if I came with it
in some way.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I might have gone
with some of them, actually.
They were...
-So, wait. This --
These are people
just walking down the street?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-They...
[ Applause ]
[ Laughs ]
That's very alluring.
-Alluring.
-Very alluring.
-Yes.
-'Cause usually,
on my first dates,
I would both have to find
someone to go on the date with
and find a pianist.
-[ Laughs ]
-So, if you can get both
at once...
-Yes, that's it. Yes.
-Did you --
So people were just walking by
and saying,
"Oh, is that Emma Thompson
in the window?"
-I don't know whether they were
thinking that, actually.
-Yeah.
-I didn't notice that,
particularly, but it was odd.
-It seems like there's somewhere
between home,
where you were
kicked out for playing...
-Yeah.
-But it seems like
there's other options
other than in the window
of an actual piano shop.
-I know.
[ Laughter ]
I'll tell you why, though --
'cause it was
a really posh piano.
-Uh-huh.
-And I had to play that piano.
-Oh, I gotcha.
-Yeah.
So, it was all just -- I had to.
There was no --
No, I had no other choice.
-All right.
Well, obviously, I take back
my earlier criticism.
-Yeah, yeah, don't. Yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't even try. Yeah.
-Your husband is an actor.
-He is.
-He was in "The Crown."
-Yes.
-First couple seasons
of "The Crown."
-Yes.
-Do you feel like,
for all British actors, like --
Dame Commander's one thing --
obviously,
that's a great accomplishment --
but that you also have to be
in shows about the royal family?
Like, that's the true thing
to aim for?
-[ Clears throat ]
I did play the Queen once,
actually...
-You did play the Queen.
-...but not well -- not well.
[ Laughter ]
She -- It was really --
It was about that moment --
Do you --
Do you remember that bloke
broke into Buckingham Palace...
- Yes.
-...and sat
on the edge of her bed
and told her him her life story?
-Yes.
-His life story -- that --
it was that.
But, I mean, I watched it
and I thought, "I don't think --
I think other people
have done it better."
I mean,
everyone's in "The Crown."
Ev-- Everyone.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It -- It's --
And I wasn't asked to be in it.
[ Laughter ]
And I feel a bit twisted
about it.
But, you know, look,
I'll have my revenge
in some way.
[ Laughter ]
-I think we're all
looking forward to that.
-Absolutely.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We're all looking forward
to that.
Now...
a part you, obviously,
played with great skill,
which was fantastic,
is Nanny McPhee,
which I've heard you say
is your favorite part.
Is that true that
it's your favorite part
that you've played?
-It sort of is, yeah.
-That's wonderful.
-Yes.
-It's so -- such a unique thing,
and now you're trying
to adapt it as a musical.
-Yes.
-"Nanny McPhee."
-I am.
-Now, that sounds to me
like a very arduous thing
to undertake.
-Yeah, there was some famous
musical producer who once said,
"If Hitler's alive,
I hope he's out of town
and working on a new musical."
[ Laughter ]
Because it's just hell,
'cause you just --
you have to chuck it all out
and then start again,
and, I mean, I've been working
on it for two years already.
-And does -- did you undertake
it knowing -- did you --
had enough people told you that,
when you started,
you thought, "This will be
a two-year process"?
Or was it --
-Yeah.
It was that kind --
-Okay.
-People would -- you'd say,
"I'm going to do this."
[ Breathing quickly ]
You know, all kind of...
And they'd sort of go,
"Mnh. Mnh."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I have --
-"We'll see you
in a couple of years," you know?
-Well, I look forward to it.
I have a lot of confidence
in you.
Please don't let me down.
-No, I'll try.
-Because that
Dame Commander stuff --
they can take that
right away from you.
-Oh, absolutely.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, 'cause my badge
could be stripped.
-[ Laughing ] They can
just show up -- and, yeah.
-Stripped of my badge.
-It's such
a pleasure having you here.
Thank you so much
for making the time.
-Oh, not at all.
[ Cheers and applause ]